♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
According to a new report,
top Democrats
are starting to worry
that President Biden
will run for re-election
in 2024,
specifically this top Democrat.
[ As Biden ] "Oh, do I have to?"
[ Laughter ]
After the House committee
investigating
the Capitol attack
showed video testimony last week
of Ivanka Trump saying
that she did not believe
her father's claims
of election fraud,
former President Trump
said that she,
"Checked out of
election results."
Though to be fair, that's just
what people used to do
after an election was over.
[ Laughter ]
The House committee
investigating the Capitol attack
today held
its second public hearing.
They weren't going to,
but then Rudy Giuliani said,
"Make it a double."
[ Laughter ]
Fox News today also aired
coverage
of the House January 6th
committee's second hearing.
Said Fox News viewers,
"Bam, I'm on TV!"
[ Laughter ]
"Remember that thing?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Police in Idaho on Saturday
arrested 31 members
of the white supremacist group
Patriot Front
after they were discovered
inside of a U-Haul truck
near an LGBTQ Pride event.
And based on the photo,
I assume
Patriot Front is
a style of khakis?
[ Laughter ]
You got flat front,
pleated front,
and Patriot Front.
And, uh, those
only come in extra small.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, you thought they were
packed into that U-Haul.
[ Laughter ]
The Labor Department
announced on Friday
that inflation has hit
a new 40-year high.
You will now pay the same amount
for a banana
at the grocery store
as you used to pay for a banana
at an airport Starbucks.
[ Laughter ]
"Forbes" magazine
announced last week
that golfer Tiger Woods is
officially a billionaire,
leaving him no choice
but to start a company
to launch him into space.
[ Laughter ]
The Tony awards
were held last night,
and "A Strange Loop"
won Best Musical.
It's the musical adaptation
of my penis.
No!
[ Laughter ]
I'm not doing that joke.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, Ikea in Norway
has launched
an online baby-name generator
based on its product line.
They just figured you should
have something from Ikea
that lasts more than a year.
In an interview
with CNN last night,
White House Press Secretary
Karine Jean-Pierre was asked
if President Biden's age
or stamina
will be a challenge
in his reelection bid.
Said Jean-Pierre, "No,
everything else will."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden criticized
large corporations
for keeping prices high
to boost profits,
in a speech last week, and said,
"Exxon made more money than God
last year."
Worse, they made it by selling
a natural resource,
so that's technically
God's money.
[ Laughter ]
During her opening statement
at yesterday's hearing
on the Capitol attack,
Republican Representative
Liz Cheney said that
an "apparently inebriated
Rudy Giuliani
told former President Trump
to falsely claim he won
on election night."
To be fair, his legal advice
doesn't get any better
when he's sober.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Are you drunk again?"
[ As Giuliani ]
Trust me, it's just as bad.
[ Laughter ]
During yesterday's congressional
hearing, it was revealed
that Donald Trump Jr.'s fiancée,
Kimberly Guilfoyle,
was paid $60,000 to speak at the
rally before the Capitol attack.
Well, technically,
$20,000 to speak
and then $40,000 to please stop.
[ Laughter ]
When asked if he will support
the bipartisan
gun legislation framework,
Republican Senator Mike Braun
said he was open to it,
but added he was,
"interested to see
where the NRA is on it,"
which is a little like saying
you're open to eating healthier,
but are interested to see
how Oreos feel about it, first.
[ Laughter ]
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
over the weekend appeared
on an episode of
"RuPaul's Drag Race All Stars."
Either that, or she didn't,
and that person should win.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean --
[ Cheering and applause ]
Mick Jagger announced yesterday
he tested positive
for the coronavirus
and Keith Richards announced
that's the only thing
he's tested negative for.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Beyoncé recently deleted
her profile pictures
on all social media platforms.
I just hope I can remember
what Beyoncé looks like.
[ Subdued laughter ]
Former President Trump
turned 76 today,
so now, he's really asking
everyone to stop the count.
[ Laughter and groans ]
That's right, today was
former President Donald Trump's
76th birthday.
Pretty impressive --
76, and he can still get
an insurrection.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
That man was our president!
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, rapper Snoop Dogg
recently tweeted
that the full-time blunt roller
he hired
now makes up to $50,000 a year,
which has to be the smallest
salary she's ever made.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
I bet they're
beautifully rolled.
[ Laughter ]
I bet they're beautifully,
artisanally rolled.
President Biden
sent a letter today
to oil companies
and called on them
to produce more in order
to alleviate high prices.
So if you needed more proof
that he's an old man,
he still thinks you can get
things done with a letter.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
According to a new poll,
President Biden's
approval rating is at 40%,
meaning that his approval rating
is the only thing
inflation hasn't touched.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans Senator Tom Cotton
reportedly met yesterday
with two dozen of his top donors
to discuss a potential
2024 presidential campaign
and said that former
President Trump's candidacy
wouldn't prevent him
from running,
only from winning.
[ Laughter ]
After recent
congressional testimony
claimed that he was drunk on
the night of the 2020 election,
Rudy Giuliani tweeted yesterday
that he had refused all alcohol
that evening
and only drank Diet Pepsi,
although being drunk sounds like
the reason you give
for drinking Diet Pepsi.
"Dude, I was so
messed up last night,
I drank a Diet Pepsi."
[ Laughter ]
The K-pop group BTS
announced yesterday
that they're going on
an indefinite hiatus.
Said President Biden,
"Aw, man!
They're gonna blame me
for this, too."
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk tweeted today
that he just voted Republican
for the first time,
but only because there were
no candidates running as Sith.
[ Laughter ]
Microsoft today formally
shut down Internet Explorer.
Well, technically,
it just shut down itself
and then they couldn't
restart it.
[ Laughter ]
A man in the UK recently
got a tattoo on his feet
that looks like a pair of shoes.
Said the man, "It hurt, but not
as much as the underwear."
[ Gasps, laughter ]
"There's just so much white."
Authorities in Michigan
recently discovered
an alligator
in the front seat of a car
during a traffic stop.
Even crazier, driver's side.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
a cooking duo on TikTok
set a Guinness World Record
by creating the world's largest
chicken nugget.
Now, for the bad news.
[ Crowd groans ]
Scollins!
The White House today announced
plans to form a task force
to combat online harassment.
Go to their website to check out
the announcement,
but head's up --
do not read the comments.
Dr. Anthony Fauci
tested positive yesterday
for a breakthrough case
of the coronavirus.
Wow. Fauci is like
COVID's final boss.
This is like hearing
that the Coyote caught
the Roadrunner.
Also, you caught it now?
You made it through
all that time
in the maskless Trump
White House
and you caught it now?
That's like running
a triathlon with no problems
and then throwing your back out
petting a dog.
[ Laughter ]
Florida yesterday
became the only state
to skip pre-ordering doses
of the coronavirus vaccine
for young children.
To be fair, Florida
doesn't have children.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in New York
this week
seized more than a dozen
Weed World Candies trucks
because some owed
more than half a million dollars
in parking tickets.
Said the drivers, "Parking?
[ Laughter ]
We thought we were speeding."
Organizers of
a British music festival
announced that rapper Lil Wayne
will no longer perform
after he was denied
entry into the UK
because on his health form
screening,
he put down that he was Weezy.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's not great,
but it tracks.
And finally, producers
of the upcoming "Barbie" movie
released a picture yesterday
of actor Ryan Gosling as Ken
with bleached blond hair
and a six pack abs,
and in homage
to the original toy,
his head was
facing the wrong way.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!